[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisirait vite vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro
le sommaire de ce jeudi du 20 juin plus
de 500 m² pour des jeux de construction
c'est ce que proposent les bâtisseurs en
herbe locaux seront transformés en salle
d'exposition pour lego playmobil les
prochains week-end découverte de ce
concept unique en france
que vous soyez du manet ou du village
vous pouvez défendre les couleurs de
votre quartier pour les olympiades de la
fête de la ville 2019
marie tooth ans sera avec nous pour
présenter le programme
le musée du petit moulin des vaux de
cernay présente sa troisième édition du
pique nique des peintres paysagistes
n'hésitez pas à arborer votre cagnottais
contre canotiers pour ces deux jeunes et
très animée c'est un concept unique en
france et en europe
un espace de jeux de construction
multiples pour les enfants si tu veux à
chambourcy les bâtisseurs en herbe
propose aux enfants et leurs parents de
s'évader dans leur monde imaginaire
elise son frère et sa soeur sont en
pleine réflexion architecturale sous les
yeux de leur maman
on cherchait justement pouvoir jouer à
tous les jeux qu'on n'a pas à la maison
dont les petits trains les grosses
briques pouvoir s'amuser puis peut-être
en demander après mon père noël plus
loin liam prépare un scénario digne de
l'agent 007 la wii il méchamment tic
sont plaints par agilis au pistolet ils
sont émises mis sur laquelle est
surveillé pour cars de police ici les
enfants dont 540 m² et de multiples jeux
de construction pour s'inventer leur
histoire ou battre des records
il ya un âge dans ses puces si on joue
encore on a un petit peu honte et du
coup on s'est dit bon voilà on va faire
un mur des records pour que les enfants
ce qu'ils aiment le challenge trouve
quelque chose encore des enfants qui se
met devant le mur noir qu'est ce que je
dois comme record aujourd'hui et après
ils ont leurs prénoms voilà c'est
valorisant aussi c'est une
reconnaissance
l'établissement unique en france a
ouvert en février 2007 pour permettre
aux parents de prendre le temps de jouer
avec leurs enfants
en plus des jeux à disposition des
animations sont organisées ces prochains
week-ends espaces se transformera en
salle d'exposition le cac vient tous les
mercredis il présentera ses
constructions que tu préfères
moi là dedans c'est ça le monde
minecraft peu moi j'ai construit chaque
bâtisseurs rooney retrouve son univers
au milieu des 37 1943 briques de
construction à disposition
[Musique]
les lui quartier de montigny le
bretonneux vont pouvoir s'affronter
dimanche 23 juin c'est la fête de la
ville avec ces olympiades un tiers
quartier marie toussaint vous êtes
conseillère municipale déléguée à
l'événementiel est la démocratie locale
bonjour bonjour alors des olympiades
interquartiers c'est la troisième
édition de sa fête une tradition annonce
ni tout à fait tous les deux ans donc en
partenariat avec le sport nous faisons
cette fête de la ville de manière à
faire découvrir de nouvelles activités
au minimum 1 ou aux autres sous forme de
défi donc les huit quartiers chaque
personne qui va arriver sur le site
coubertin ce à coubertin cette année
avant c'était ladoumègue
donc chaque personne recevra un bracelet
de couleur différente pour s'identifier
avec son quartier ainsi qu'une carte
qu'elle fera poissonnet passionner
chaque défi réaliser nous on dit ça
commence à 14h vous avez des exemples de
défis
les défis donc au niveau sportif on a
une trentaine d'associations sportives
qui seront présentes sur le site
à savoir donc le foot le hand le basket
le volley la pétanque l'athlétisme
quatre sports 4 arts martiaux
nous avons en nous obligeant nous glisse
le goal c'est l'occasion de présenter
ces associations de faire découvrir et
de s'initier de pouvoir s'initier à ce
sport et après pourquoi pas le pratiquer
pour la saison prochaine et comme on dit
c'est une fête c'est par équipes
enfin chacun représente son quartier
chacun représente son quartier chacun
défend son quartier ou le quartier de
son choix
alors c'est que c'est lequel le quartier
à battre celui qui a déjà déjà gagné les
deux précédentes éditions elle en avait
deux précédents
les deux précédentes éditions par do
c'est le village aux deux fois donc
cette année venez nombreux pour défier
le village et représentez votre quartier
justement vous attendez du monde
d'habitude vous avez combien de
personnes à peu près alors nous avons eu
de la chance les deux précédentes
éditions nous avons eu beau temps donc
beau temps veut dire beaucoup de monde
donc je sais pas 3000 5000 personnes
peuvent venir sachant qu'il y en a
vraiment pour tout le monde à toutes les
familles c'est vraiment
intergénérationnel nous avons également
huit structures gonflables avec des
parcours des parcours de combat d nous
avons également du karting du du curling
du surf du surf mécanique
donc ça c'est sympa il n'a vraiment pour
tous les âges et aussi une structure
gonflable pour les 2 5 ans pour les tout
petits montages à nous et voilà tout à
fait ça choque montigny jimmy rossi
représenter pour les tout petits c'est
important aussi pensé à vous et pourquoi
pas redonner cet aspect un peu
olympiades à cette fête de la ville au
début c'est vrai que c'était un
challenge interquartiers et après
olympia donc ça tombe bien parce que le
23 septembre c'est la journée
internationale du 23 juin portant le 23
juin c'est la journée internationale des
olympiades dont continue s'associe
également à cette journée internationale
même la fête du sport et même à montigny
d'autres rendez-vous à montigny pour cet
été alors j'ai pas terminée sur la fête
de la ville nous avons aussi
l'initiation au trapèze volant donc que
chaque personne pourra s'initier au
trapèze et enfin demain en fin de
journée nous avons un spectacle de
trapèze
donc venez nombreux parce que c'est
vraiment joli vraiment vraiment donc
même du spectacle c'est pas que du sport
à faire soi même s'ils se reposent et
voilà que j'avais fait en fin de journée
lorsque vous aurez fait toutes les
activités vous serez bien fatigué vous
pourrez assister à un spectacle de
qualité
je reviens à ma question la fête a
continué sa vague tout l'été parce qu'il
y aura d'autres événements qui vont
arriver tout à fait donc après durant
l'été elle était en sable donc là c'est
tout l'été donc sous un format différent
sachant qu'il faut
avoir sa carte pour pouvoir montrer
cette année elle était en sable parce
que tellement de succès que vous êtes
obligés et la sécurité la pose est donc
voilà donc cette année il faudra venir
est traîné montagne à venir avec sa
carte très bien la merci beaucoup paris
tout semble être venu sur notre plateau
ces olympiades c'est ce dimanche 23 juin
à partir de 14 heures au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin après montini
direction trappe trappe en fait mais
cette année le cirque à l'honneur des
déambulations des spectacles et des
animations
tout est réuni pour fêter l'été avec
bien sûr le feu d'artifice à 23 heures
rendez vous samedi après midi au stade
grave ou le 21 juin vous le savez c'est
la fête de la musique les communes
divine oise ne manquons pas de rythme
croissy-sur-seine profite de la présence
des joueuses de football américaine pour
la coupe du monde féminine pour faire
une thématique 100% us est à vendre et
lyon vous propose de sortir vos
instruments et de vous installer dans la
rue quel que soit votre style retrouver
encore plus de détails sur les diverses
programmations dans le 7-8 culture du
mardi 18 juin sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme et la musique fait
également résonner les films c'est votre
rubrique dans les salles
saint-quentinoise de patrick jane et 10
mai
[Musique]
le vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir basile dogue a nice c'est
lamine sissoko pour leur film meltem
cissokho est un trappistes qui a
commencé un petit peu sa carrière dans
le cinéma dans la vidéo par les ateliers
etc la ville de trappes
maintenant il est dans un long métrage
son premier long métrage il avait déjà
tourné un court-métrage avec basile
d'organismes et ils se sont retrouvés
pour ce long métrage donc mais le thème
c'est l'histoire de trois jeunes
français qui partent en vacances on
était sur une île grecque et leurs
vacances sont un petit peu bouleversée
par la rencontre avec un réfugié syrien
dans cette île grecque
on suit leur histoire
à tous les trois tous les cartes
maintenant avec ces réfugiés et donc on
aura la chance d'avoir les trois acteurs
principaux et le réalisateur qui
viendront nous parler de ce film ça sera
vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 procinema le
grenier à sel pour trouver tout ça sur
cinéma grenier à sel points comme de
vence laisse pantois
xs rampeau mais sans racines là je sais
même pas où tu vas tu es notre honte tu
va sauver le monde
or hélas
[Musique]
alors
c'est une plongée au coeur du 19e siècle
que vous propose le petit moulin des
veaux de cerner ce dimanche 23 juin de
11h à 17h revêtez vos costumes d'époque
pour un pique nique des peintres au
programme des saynètes et des nappes et
des animations tout au long de la
journée pour tous les publics le tout
clôturé par un bal champêtre pascal
camus était sur le plateau de 7,8
culture pour parler de cette troisième
édition
il ya plein d'associations justement qui
ont aidé aussi à la création de ces
petits moulins qui a été ouvert en
septembre 2007 donc on a plus en plus de
visiteurs l'année dernière pour
l'édition des peintres paysagistes
on avait plus de 600 visiteurs donc
c'est quand même un chiffre relativement
important et de la toile à la scène la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt fait son
festival de théâtre amateur 3 spectacle
du jeudi 20 au dimanche 23 juin c'est
gratuite sur réservation la revanchard
de revient pour une 21e édition les 200
participants à la finale du challenge
vtt tour s'élanceront pour un circuit de
6 km sur la colline d'elancourt
si l'expérience vous tente vous pouvez
vous inscrire en ligne directement sur
place le jour j à partir de 7 heures ce
dimanche 23 juin dimanche 23 juin c'est
aussi la journée olympique vélodrome et
golf nationaux vous ouvrent leurs portes
pour cette grande fête du sport
de nombreuses activités sont à découvrir
sur ces sites retenus pour l'accueil des
jeux olympiques 2024 vous pourrez
retrouver plus d'informations dans le
7-8 hebdo du vendredi 21 juin et
maintenant direction paris pour prendre
de la hauteur
[Musique]
elle trône au milieu du square qui porte
son nom la tour saint-jacques rouvre ses
portes sébastien côté de nos confrères
via grand paris vous la fais visiter
malgré ses cinquante quatre mètres de
hauteur
elle est presque discrète situé en face
de l'hôtel de ville en plein coeur de la
capitale la tour saint-jacques est
inscrite dans le patrimoine parisien
après des travaux
elle rouvre ses portes au public la tour
médiévale date du 16e siècle construite
entre 1509 et 1523 elle fut le clocher
de l'église saint jacques la boucherie
au 16ème siècle les bouchers qui sont
devenus une force majeure dans le
paysage parisien décide d'avoir un
clocher à l'image de ce pouvoir l'image
de la richesse qui est la leur dont qui
ont financé ce clocher monumentale et ce
clocher c'est le deuxième plus haut de
paris pour atteindre le clocher pas
d'ascenseur l'ascension se fait dans le
noir l'escalier est raide 300 marches à
gravir
mais avant d'atteindre notre but arrêt
obligatoire dans cette pièce remplie
d'histoire elle aurait accueilli blaise
pascal pour ses expériences avant de
devenir une fabrique de plomb au fil des
années la tour subi de nombreuses
transformations au milieu du 19e siècle
paris intègre l'observatoire municipal
de météorologie de montsouris l'ancêtre
de météo france qui s'installe ici c'est
pour ça que vous avez des bouteilles de
produits chimiques vous avez des
réchauds
vous avez l'état d'avoir métal vous êtes
une installation en fait pendant
longtemps les ingénieurs météo sont
venus ici pour calculer la pression pour
calculer pour paiera tueur pour imaginer
vous êtes dans l'espèce de bureaux et
dans un laboratoire
ça va durer très longtemps encore
quelques instants d'efforts on accède
enfin à la terrasse gardé par ses
gargouilles
mais la récompense c'est la vue à 360°
sur la capitale la tour se visite
jusqu'au 3 novembre
l'entrée coûte entre 8 et 10 euros
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 loisirs merci
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties
[Musique]
oh